[Musik]
wie finden sie etwa kirchen sankt oswald
und üben eine grundl bergung anna
brunner sparen
die große ausnahme ist vor allem für
piloten der ist am ehesten gefordert der
bus schweben heißt es bei widrigen
verhältnissen bei böigen wind und die
sagen jetzt sehr knopf bei den lift
seele dabei die nächste herausforderung
seine für ein techniker die erde oder
der davinci verräter der aber aus den
flugretter direkt zur gründlichen
unterlässt wo das winter sei ebenfalls
sehr knapp
bei der grundlage und ebenfalls auf die
zusammenarbeit mit die bergretter die
wurst jetzt mit dem hubschrauber nicht
so geschult sind 2018 neujahrs
flugretter bei der lift bergung gesperrt
doubai und da war die große
herausforderung die 150 skitouristen
rechtzeitig vom lift herunterzubringen
das war glaube ich schon 15 uhr begonnen
haben mit der bergung und insgesamt
waren wurden glaube wir fünf
hubschrauber an der bergung beteiligt
und innerhalb von drei stunden haben
eigentlich 150 skitouristen vom lift
geboren mit den letzten tageslicht
eigentlich alle waren unverletzt und
froh dass jährlich kunden sind von lift
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bemerkungen ziemlich kompliziert es ist
relativ bürger winterwind es ein
ziemliches kriterium für diese art
verbindungen dass die bergung ansicht er
ist immer sehr präzises fliegen fragt
und die zusammenarbeit in der besatzung
zwischen piloten und bohrtechnik und
saubere position ein heute bedient und
dem piloten auf die spielposition hinein
weist dann muss man vielleicht die
anweisungen genau bevor ich jetzt einmal
als unternehmer wurde von der
anweisungen und internet bis zum boden
machen ist es ein schweben die gondeln
kann sie leicht bewegen von daimler
schon vom wind also garantiert sauber
war das glaube ich ganz gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die flugretter 1 innsbruck wird für
einsätze herangezogen wenn es darum geht
waldbrände zu bekämpfen
nach heftigen schneefällen oder noch
sonstigen unglücksfällen wo eben sie die
zivilen einsatzkräfte nicht auskommen
bzw unterstützung durch das heer
benötigen
meine aufgabe konkret als commander
flugretter einsatzgruppe süd hieß es
dafür zu sorgen dass bereitschaftsleiter
für jeder kalenderwoche des jahres
bereitstellt sollte es zu solchen
unglücksfällen kommen und eben dann zum
einsatz gebracht wird konkret in solchen
unglücksfällen wäre es dann auch meine
aufgabe als einsatzleiter den einsatz
der flugretter zu koordinieren und eben
auch zum einsatz zu bringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die flugzeit und die hubschrauber hat
üben die lieferung heute mal für uns ist
es extrem gefährlich die letzten ganzer
meter
die lifte seile dass wir heute im auge
haben und uns nun mit der hubschrauber
auge mannschaften immer absprechen die
leute was machen die sind meistens so
sehr emotional und aufgeregt und es ist
unsere aufgabe das man bislang kommen
und unter anderen die unbeschadet wieder
überbringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eines der größten schwierigkeiten bei
dieser übung heute waren die
windverhältnisse speziell in den bergen
ist man es gewohnt dass der wind sich
sehr stark ändert und sehr schnell
ändert das hat man hat hier in diesem
bereich auch kommt der wind das signal
in richtung gekommen
in jeder stärke und das ist eine große
schwierigkeit wenn man mit dem
hubschrauber bergungen von lift stützen
macht oder von lift gonnen macht war
natürlich alles in bewegung ist weiters
kann man zu dieser übung sagen dass die
zusammenarbeit mit der bergrettung und
der feuerwehr und speziell hier auch mit
den mitstreitern sehr gut funktioniert
hat das sind alles profis in ihren
bereich dann war da auch der ablauf
äußerst flüssig und schnell und um es
auch in dieser kurzer zeit so viel
übungsinhalte in dieser übung
untergebracht worden
danke es ja
[Musik]